ROLL.
PORTANTINO I'M HERE PORTANTINO
HERE BATES BATES HERE BRADFORD
DORADO.
DORADO HERE HILL.
JONES WE CAL SKI.
CASKEY HERE.
SO WE HAVE A QUORUM -- WE HAVE.
FORTY NINE BILLS HERE TO HEAR
TODAY TWELVE A WHICH ARE DUE
PASS MOTIONS.
OUR RECOMMENDATIONS THE
REMAINING BILLS ARE FOR SUSPENSE.
THE FOLLOWING BILLS ON FILE WILL
NOT BE HEARD TODAY A. B. FOUR
FIVE A FINE IS ERIN WAS PULLED.
FOR THE PURPOSES OF AMENDMENTS
AND S. A. B. SEVEN NINETY EIGHT
BY CERVANTES IS NOW IT TO YOUR
BILL -- AS REMINDER I'D LIKE TO
REITERATE OUR MESSAGE TO THE
AUDIENCE A MEMBERS THE TESTIMONY
SHOULD BE LIMITED TO THE
PHYSICAL ASPECTS OF THE BILL.
I SAY THAT EVERY TIME AND NOBODY
LISTENS TO ME.
SO LET'S TRY A NEW TREND TODAY
AND LIMóN ARE TESTIMONY TO THE
FISCAL IMPACTS OF THE BILL.
SO REFRAIN FROM LAND FLEA POLICY
DISCUSSIONS YOU HAD THAT
OPPORTUNITY ARE READY.
AND THEN WE'RE GOING.
TO OBVIOUSLY CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS -- AND I SEE MISTER
KALRA IS HERE.
SEE IF THERE'S A PAGE TO WE'VE
ALREADY DONE THAT OKAY.
SO MISTER KALRA ARE YOU THE ONLY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PLEASE COME UP
AND TELL US ABOUT YOUR BILL.
WHICH IS AT THE VERY VERY BOTTOM.
SEVENTEEN FORTY FIVE IT'S A DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER CHAIR --
MY AYE EVEN THOSE THAT THE AND I
THOUGHT IF I GOT HERE AND I GET
LUCKY.
SO I REALLY APPRECIATED THE THE
BRIDGE HOUSING COMMITTEES
PROGRAM IS A SUNSET DATED
JANUARY FIRST TWENTY TWO TWENTY
TWO AB SEVENTY FORTY FIVE WOULD
EXTEND THE SUNSET. TWENTY TWENTY
FIVE TO ALLOW THE BRIDGE HOUSING
PROJECT OPERATE TRADITIONAL
YEARS -- SITE ONE WILL BE READY
PROJECT ESTIMATES ARE BETWEEN
NINETEEN SAID TO BE READY LATE
SUMMER TWENTY NINETEEN ASSET IN
THE NOW STERN NEWS NO NEW STATE
COSTS EXPECTED WITH EXTENDING
THE SUNSET RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
MY BOOK.
YEAH WITNESSES IN SUPPORT ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
IS THERE A FILE.
YES GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS JULIE ON AIR WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE A WE
DON'T HAVE AN APPROVED POSITION
ON THIS BILL BUT WOULD CONCUR
WITH COMMITTEES ANALYSIS OF NO
NEW STATE COSTS -- AND NO
REIMBURSABLE STATE MANAGE COSTS
THANK YOU WONDERFUL THANK YOU.
WE HAVE A MOTION.
WAS LIKE THAT FROM EITHER
THINKING SHOWER RIGHT I DON'T
SEE ANY QUESTIONS SO WITH THAT
WE WILL CALL THE VAULT THE CALL
THE VOTE ON SEVENTEEN FORTY FIVE
PORTANTINO.
AYE PORTANTINO AYE BATES BATES
AYE BRADFORD TO RAZA.
TERRAZZO AYE HILL JONES WE CAL
SKI.
WE CASKEY AYE.
WE WILL KEEP THAT OPEN BUT YOU
HAVE THE NECESSARY VOTES TO GET
OUT THANK YOU SIR THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT THERE ARE NO OTHER
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS HERE SO WE WILL
GO TO A. B..
THIRTY MR HOLDEN WHICH IS A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE.
NO QUESTIONS.
WITHOUT OBJECTION A. B. THIRTY
WILL GO TO SUSPENSE.
WE HAVE.
ANOTHER AUTHORED RIGHT.
WHERE ARE YOU I'M LOOKING ON MY
LIST MR CHAN [inaudible]
YOU CAN.
TWELVE THIRTEEN THERE YOU ARE
TWELVE THIRTEEN TO DO PASS
PLEASE COME UP.
SUPPORT SUPPORT ON BOTH SIDES IN
THE DO PASS PLEASE PROCEED THANK
YOU MISTER NUMBERS -- YOUR TIME
A. B. TWELVE THIRTY WORKS AND
JOIN YOUR ONE TWENTY TWENTY ONE
LEGAL DOCUMENTS ASSISTANT LDA
SUNSET TO GERMANY. ONE TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR LEGAL DOCUMENTS AS
HAVE PROVIDED SELF EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITIES FOR WIDE RANGE OF
NEW AND EXPERIENCE LEGAL
PROFESSIONALS.
AND OTHERS ARE PLEASE DID NOT
EXIST THIS BILL HAS MINOR IT WAS
HORRIBLE COSTS THE STATE.
HAS HAD ZERO NO VOTES.
HERE WITH ME IF YOU HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS AS MASS OVERLAND
GROUPS IN THE CALIFORNIA LEGAL
DOCUMENTS ASSISTANCE.
MISTER CHAMBERS MASS AYE REELING
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF LEGAL DOCUMENT
ASSISTANCE WITHOUT BEING TOO
REPETITIVE WE BELIEVE THIS.
PROPOSAL IS VIRTUALLY COST
NEUTRAL WITH THE REGISTRATION
FEE PAID BY ALL THE ETS EMITTER
DRIVE A THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
IS THERE ARE.
I DON'T KNOW FILE ON THIS NO
FINAL ON THIS BILL OTHER
QUESTIONS.
NO QUESTIONS WE HAVE A MOTION BY
MISTER WHITE CASKET WHICH LIKE
TO CLOSE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVALS FOR MY
FAVORITECLOTHES ALL RIGHT WITH
THAT WILL TAKE THE VOTE.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
NO HI PORTANTINO AYE BATES
[inaudible]
BRADFORD.
DORADO DORADO AYE HILL
[inaudible]
JONES.
WE CAL SKI.
BECAUSE THE I WILL KEEP THAT ON
CALL FIGURES SURE THANK YOU
LETTER ANY OTHER FAMILY MEMBERS
IN THE HOUSE NONE.
WE WILL GO BACK TO ITEM A. B.
THIRTY SEVEN BY MISTER JONES
SAWYER -- IS THERE ANYONE HERE
WHO WANTS TO SPEAK ON A. B.
[inaudible] THIRTY EIGHTY SEVEN
N FAVOR [inaudible]
HAMANA.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
TRACY STEVENS ON BEHALF OF NOR
CAL CANNABIS IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING ERIN NORWOOD ON
BEHALF OF THE CAMPUS
DISTRIBUTION ASSOCIATION ALSO IN
SUPPORT.
SIR ANY OPPOSITION DAY BE.
THIRTY SEVEN ARE THERE QUESTIONS
ON A. B..
THIRTY SEVEN SEEING NONE WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB THIRTY SEVEN WILL
GO TO SUSPENSE.
AB SEVENTEEN NINETY FOUR BY
MISTER JONES SAWYER ON ON SAVE
HANDGUN.
EXEMPTIONS ANYBODY HERE IN
SUPPORT.
OF AB.
SEVENTEEN NINETY FOUR SIR
ANYBODY HERE IN OPPOSITION OF
SEVENTEEN NINETY FOUR BY MISTER
JONES SAWYER.
SEEING NONE OTHER ANY QUESTIONS
SEEING NONE -- WITHOUT OBJECTION
AB SEVENTEEN NINETY FOUR WILL GO
TO SUSPENSE MOVINGTO MISTER
MARSH TO CHEESE BILLS.
AB -- THIRTY NINE ON LOCAL
CONTROL FUNDING TO ANYBODY HERE
IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING SENATOR AND
COMMITTEE KATHY HALL WITH THE
CALIFORNIA STATE PTA IN SUPPORT.
MORNING MR TERROR MEMBERS RON
RAP ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS AND
SUPPORT.
SURE ANY OPPOSITION.
MANY QUESTIONS SCENE NINE
WITHOUT OBJECTION A. B. THIRTY
NINE WILL GO TO SUSPENSE.
AB.
THREE FORTY TWO HI -- MISTER
MARSHALL CHEN PUBLIC LANDS IS
THERE ANYBODY HERE -- I DIDN'T
ASK.
FOR I'VE LEFT YOU OUT ONE THIRTY
NINE WE DON'T HAVE AN APPROVED
PHYSICIAN -- BUT WOULD KNOW THAT
THE BILL CREATES PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT GENERAL FUND COST
PRESSURES OF APPROXIMATELY
THIRTY FIVE BILLION DOLLARS A BY
INCREASING BY INCREASING THE
LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA
THE SPRINT TARGET RATES.
THANK YOU I'M SORRY -- SO.
NOW WE'LL GO -- TO SUSPENSE
MOVIE ON A. B. THREE FORTY TWO
PUBLIC LANDS MISTER MURATSUCHI
IS ANYBODY IN SUPPORT.
THAT'S WHAT TO DO PASS I'M SORRY.
THAT'S MY FAULT.
AT TO DO PASS WE WILL COME BACK
TO THAT WHEN HE'S HERE.
AND I SEE MISTER FRAZIER WALKED
IN THE ROOM.
MR DAILY YOU'RE PRESENTING ON
BEHALF OF MR DAILY THERE IT IS
AB.
TWO FIVE TWO ON TRANSPORTATION
ENVIRONMENTAL POLICY PLEASE COME
TELL US ALL ABOUT THIS AND THIS
IS A SUPPORT SUPPORT WITH THE
CHAIR'S RECOMMENDATION OF A TO
PASS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN VERS
CALIFORNIA'S SUCCESSFULLY
PARTICIPATED IN THE NATIONAL
ENVIRONMENTAL POLICY ACT NEPA.
WHO'S THE ASSIGNMENT PROGRAM
SINCE TWO THOUSAND SIX THIS BILL
REMOVES A SUNSET TO ALLOW
CALTRANS TO CONTINUE
PARTICIPATION IN NEED TO
DECISION MAKING.
THIS ENABLES CALTRANS TO
STREAMLINE TRANSPORTATION
PROJECTS WITHOUT COMPROMISING
COMPLIANCE WITH ENVIRONMENTAL
LAWS AND REGULATIONS.
WITH ME TODAY'S KEATON
REPRESENTING THE SELF HELP
COUNTIES COLLISION WHO'LL SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL -- AT
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR -- JUST
ADDED TO THE ANALYSIS BY THE
STAFF PROVIDED THAT IN ADDITION
TO STATE SAVINGS IS ALSO STATE
SAVES LOCAL COUNTY --
TRANSPORTATION AGENCIES TENS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS EACH YEAR IN
TIME SAVINGS.
A CRITICALLY IMPORTANT BILL AND
WE'RE PLEASE AT THE SUNSET IS
FINALLY BEING REMOVED AND WE
WOULD ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
RIGHT ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT ANYBODY HERE IN
OPPOSITION.
ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS ON SB.
TWO FIVE TWO SEEING NONE --
FINANCE FINANCE IS NEUTRAL IN
THIS MEASURE FINANCES NEUTRAL AS
THEIR MOTION.
WE HAVE A MOTION IS THERE CLOSE
I JUST RESPECTFULLY US RIGHT.
FANTASTIC WITH THAT WILL CALL
THE ROLL ON A. B. TWO FIVE TWO
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
SENATE FLOOR PORTANTINO AYE
PORTANTINO AYE BATES
[inaudible]
BRADFORD.
DRAWS.
TORONTO I HELD.
JONES.
JONES I WE CASKEY HI WE CASKEY
AYE.
WE WILL HOLD THAT HONOR.
CALL THANK YOU SIR THANK YOU%
MISTER YOU GOT I SAW MR MATH.
MEDINA SHOWS UP [inaudible]
COMMA.
TELL US ABOUT AB SIX NINETY FIVE
ON COMMUNITY COLLEGE DESIGN
BUILD.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MMBERS.
SB.
SIX NINETY FIVE EXTENDS THE
CURRENT CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DESIGNED BILLS STATUTE.
UNTIL.
TWENTY THIRTY ACCORDING TO
EXPERIENCES FROM COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICTS THE USE DESIGN
BUILD CONTRACTING. TO EXPEDIA
EIGHT THE CONSTRUCTION OF THE
PROJECT.
AVOID CONFLICTS BETWEEN
ARCHITECTS ENGINEERS AND
CONTRACTORS.
AND REDUCE COSTS.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR I'VE.
WE HAVE WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN OF THE
COMMITTEE JEREMY SMITH HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE STATE BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL JUST
VERY BRIEFLY NOTE THAT.
ALL REQUIRING THE USE OF A
SCHOOL TO TRAIN WORKFORCE OF
WHAT LOWER COSTS FOR COMMUNITY
COLLEGES MAKE SURE THAT THE
SCHOOLS ARE BUILT THE HIGHEST
QUALITY STANDARDS WE ARE DRIVER.
OTHER WITNESSES.
JUSTIN SILICON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE IN SUPPORT.
GRAY IS THERE ANYBODY IN
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE FINANCE WE DON'T
HAVE AN APPROVED POSITION BUT
WOULD NOTE THAT WE DON'T EXPECT
THIS BILL TO CREATE MANDATE A OR
TO CREATE PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT GENERAL FUND COST
PRESSURES.
THE BROTHER ANY QUESTIONS.
SINGER WE HAVE A MOTION MISTER
WHAT CASKEY MISTER MEDINA WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE THIS
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE FANTASTIC WILL CALL THE
ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
SENATE FLOOR PORTANTINO AYE
PORTANTINO AYE BATES.
BATES NO BRADFORD. TO RAZA
DORADO AYE HILL.
JONES.
JONES I WE KOWSKI BECAUSE HE AYE.
THAT BILLS ON CALL THANK YOU WE
WILL GO TO S. A. B. FIFTEEN NOW
FOR COMMITTEE COLLEGE STUDENT
FEES.
SO AB FIFTEEN OH FOUR DUE TO
LACK OF RESOURCES THE STUDENTS
SENATE THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES.
HAVE VIRTUALLY NO PRESENCE IN
THE STATE CAPITOL AND LITTLE TO
NO ABILITY TO ADVOCATE FOR
LEGISLATION.
THAT AFFECTS CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS.
AB FIFTEEN OH FOUR WILL ENSURE
THAT A TWO DOLLAR.
STUDENT REPRESENT STUDENT
REPRESENTATION FEE.
IS IMPLEMENTED AT ALL CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
BY COLLECTING IT FROM STUDENTS
UPON PAYMENT A REGISTRATION FEES.
THIS WAS A A BILL THAT STUDENTS
BROUGHT UP TO ME.
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS
ASKED ME TO DO ON THEIR BEHALF
THIS BILL WILL HELP ENSURE.
THAT COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS
HAVE AN EQUAL VOICE WHEN IT
COMES TO POLICIES AND
LEGISLATION THAT IMPACTS THE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE
ONE YEAH WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
JUSTIN SILICON FOR THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
CHANCES OFFICE IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
ANY OPPOSITION [inaudible]
THEIR FILE.
YES -- WE DON'T HAVE AN APPROVED
POSITION -- BUT WE KNOW THAT THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE ESTIMATES
THIS BILL WILL LIKELY CREATE
BETWEEN SEVEN MILLION TO EIGHT
MILLION DOLLARS AND FEE REVENUE --
HALF OF WHICH WOULD BE PROVIDED
TO SUPPORT THE STUDENTS SENATE
FOR CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES THE REMAINDER -- WITH
SUPPORT LOCAL STUDENT BODY
ASSOCIATIONS -- WE WOULD
ADDITIONALLY NOTE THIS BILL
COULD CREATE A REIMBURSABLE
STATE MANDATE.
IF YOU PUT IF THE APPLICABLE
OFFSETTING STUDENT FEE REVENUES
ARE INSUFFICIENT TO COVER EACH
COLLEGES COSTS TO COLLECT THE
FEE.
THANK YOU OTHER QUESTIONS
[inaudible]
SIR MOTION.
WE HAVE A MOTION WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE.
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL AND
TASTIC WILL TAKE THE REMOTE ON
FIFTEEN FOR THE MOTION IS TO%
PASS TO THE SENATE FLOOR
PORTANTINO AYE PORTANTINO AYE
BATES.
BATES NO BRADFORD.
THE RAZA DORADO AYE HILL
[inaudible]
JONES.
JONES NO WE CASKEY.
CASKEY AYE.
THE BILL IS ON CALL THANK YOU.
I DON'T SEE ANY OTHER ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SO WE WILL GO BACK TO MR
LACKEY AB.
ONE SIX NINE ON SERVICE DOGS IS
THERE ANYBODY HERE IN SUPPORT OF
AB.
ONE SIX NINE ANYBODY OPPOSED --
TO ONE SIX NINE FILE ON ONE SIX
NINE WE DON'T HAVE AN APPROVED
POSITION -- WOULD KNOW REQUIRING
A LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS
TO REMAIN ON THE SCENE -- COULD
CREATE SUCH COULD BE SUBJECT TO
REIMBURSEMENT BY THE STATE THE
MAGNITUDE OF WHICH IS UNKNOWN --
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
ESTIMATES COSTS OF SEVENTEEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS GENERAL FUND IN
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY AND
TWENTY SEVEN THOUSAND DOLLARS
GENERAL FUND IN.
TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY ONE A FOR
ON GOING COST IMPLEMENT THE
MEASURE.
A AND LASTLY THE VICTIM
COMPENSATION BOARD INDICATES --
ANY CLAIMS RESULTING FROM THIS
BILL WOULD BE MINOR AN
OBSERVABLE.
THANK YOU -- CHINO QUESTIONS
WITHOUT OBJECTION AB ONE SIX
NINE WILL GO TO SUSPENSE.
GONNA GO ON A. B. TWO ELEVEN BY
MISTER CALDERON ON CALIFORNIA
QUALIFIED TUITION PROGRAM IS
ANYBODY IN SUPPORT. TO ELEVEN
ANY OPPOSITION.
TO TO ELEVEN AT THE HALL FOR THE
CALIFORNIA STATE PTA IN
OPPOSITION [inaudible]
CAN.
WE HAVE ANOTHER.
MY APOLOGIES GIVE ME.
JOANNE BUT IN COURT REPRESENTING
THE SECURITIES INDUSTRY.
AND FINANCIAL MARKETS
ASSOCIATION.
SIFMA WE HAVE A SUPPORT IF
AMENDED POSITION IT'S BASED ON
PARITY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SIR FILE ON TWO ELEVEN
THE FRANCHISE TAX BOARD
ESTIMATES GENERAL FUND REVENUE
LOSSES OF FIVE POINT SIX MILLION
IN. TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY
TWELVE MILLION DOLLARS IN TWENTY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND THIRTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS AND TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO BOTH THE
FRANCHISE TAX BOARD AND THE
SCHOLARS YOUR INVESTMENT BOARD.
A HAE DETERMINE THIS BILL AND
NOT SIGNIFICANTLY IMPACT THEIR
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS.
THANK YOU WITHOUT OBJECTION AB
TWO ELEVEN WILL GO TO SUSPENSE.
WE'RE GOING TO GO ON TO MISTER
DALY'S SECOND BILL WHICH IS AB
THIRTEEN NINETY FOUR ON JUVENILE
CEILING OF RECORDS. TO ANYBODY
IN SUPPORT OF THIRTEEN NINETY
FOUR ANY OPPOSITION AT THIRTEEN
NINETY FOUR IS OUR FILE AND
THIRTY NO FILE SEE NO QUESTIONS.
WITHOUT OBJECTION AB THIRTEEN
NINETY FOUR GO TO SUSPENSE
MISTER COOPER'S WORKERS COMP.
AB THREE FOUR SIX IS THERE
ANYBODY HERE IN SUPPORT.
OF AB.
THREE FORTY SIX I SEE A COUPLE.
CENTER BOROUGH ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL EMPLOYEES
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
WHICH DUGGAR WITH THE CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION ALSO IN SUPPORT.
ALL RIGHT ANY OPPOSITION.
THE THREE FORTY SIX SIR FILE.
WE DON'T HAVE AN APPROVED
POSITION -- BUT WOULD KNOW THAT
THIS BILL MAY INCREASE WORKERS
COMPENSATION COSTS FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS.
AS WELL AS INCREASE PROPOSITION
NINETY GENERAL FUND COST
PRESSURES FOR SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
ADDITIONALLY TO THE EXTENT THE
COMMISSION ON STATE MANDATES
FIND THIS BILL -- IS A
REIMBURSABLE STATE MANDATE THERE
COULD BE ADDITIONAL STATE COSTS.
SEEING NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB THREE FORTY SIX
WILL GO TO SUSPENSE.
MOVING ON TO QUIRK SILVA SCHOOL
MEALS.
AB.
THREE FIVE FOUR COME ON UP
SUPPORT.
BROWN WRAPPING BE UP TO THE
CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS AND SUPPORT.
THEIR OPPOSITION THE THREE FIVE
FOUR SEEING NONE IS THERE A FILE.
NO APPROVED POSITION -- BUT WE
KNOW THAT THE BILL COULD CREATE
A REIMBURSABLE STATE MANDATE
THAT COULD COST HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS TO MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT GENERAL
FUND.
WONDERFUL SEEING NO QUESTIONS
WITHOUT OBJECTION AB THREE FIFTY
FOUR WE'LL GO TO SUSPENSE MISTER
RIVAS.
HAS JOINED US AND YOU HAVE ONE
BILL 2% WHICH IS A TO PASS.
AB.
TWELVE FIFTY TWO IT IS A SUPPORT
SUPPORT WITCHER'S RECOMMENDATION
PLEASE TELL US ABOUT TWELVE
FIFTY TWO MISTER CHAIR AND
CENTERS THANKS FOR HAVING ME
THIS MORNING HAS GREAT TO BE
HERE SO SOME OF THE OFF TOPIC TO
TO IS.
LEGISLATION REALLY TO THE
CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL
PROTECTION AGENCY AND
ADMINISTERED SMALL GRANT PROGRAM.
AS A CURRENTLY HAD THE KELLY PA
PROVIDES GRANTS TO COMMUNITY
BASED NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS --
TO HELP ADDRESS MY MIL JUST
ISSUES IN THESE GRANT PAYMENTS
MAXIMUM WARDS OF FIFTY THOUSAND
ARE WE ARE AWARDED UPON THE
COMPLETION OF PROGRAM WORK -- AS
REIMBURSEMENT FOR APPROVED
PROJECTS UNFORTUNATELY.
SMALL ORGANIZATIONS ARE ALWAYS
ABLE TO PUT UP BY THE INITIAL
COST OF THESE PROGRAMS.
AND ARE DETERRED FROM APPLYING
FOR FIND IT IN THE FIRST PLACE
AND SO ESSENTIALLY THIS BILL
WOULD GIVE.
THE KELLY PAY A FORTY TO PROVIDE
ADVANCE -- THESE PAYMENTS
SHORTIES WHICH WILL RELIEVE THE
FINANCIAL PRESSURE ON THE SMALL
ORGANIZATIONS IS NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS.
THEY COULD ALSO BOOST THE
PARTICIPATION ENCOURAGE MORE
ORGANIZATIONS TO PIPER FINDING
AND REALLY DRIVE THESE PROJECTS
LOCALLY AND SO -- TWELVE FIFTY
TO THE GOOD GOVERNMENT MEASURE
WITH OBSERVABLE COSTS IS A BILL
THAT IS RECEIVED.
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
WE DO HAVE SOME BILL SPONSORS.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS MARIA ROGER
FROM CALIFORNIA RELIEF A NETWORK
OF OVER HUNDRED ORGANIZATION
STATEWIDE DROUGHT THE KIND OF
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
COMMITTED TO PROMOTING URBAN
FORTUNE IRVINE GRAINY -- WE
AGREE WITH THE COMMITTEE --
STUFF THAT.
COMMITTEE STAFF THAT.
THE NATURE OF THE SMALL GRANTS
INHERENTLY MINIMIZED.
RISKS TO MISUSE FUNDS WE SEE
ADDITIONAL COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH
ACCOUNTABILITY CONTROLS TO
PREVENT THE MISUSE OF FUNDS AS
BEING OBSERVABLE GIVEN THE
AMOUNT OF DETAIL IN INFORMATION
THAT MST.
ALREADY BE PROVIDED BY
APPLICANTS AND REVIEWED BY THE
AGENCY STAFF FOR CURRENT --
GRANTS CARRY A WILL HAVE THE
FLEXIBILITY TO DETERMINE IF AND
HOW TO MEASURES. TO ADMINISTER
EVENTS PAYMENTS ON A CASE BY
CASE BASIS -- FOR THESE REASONS
WE RESPECTFULLY ASK THREE AYE
VOTE.
IN ANY OTHER WITNESSES SINCE
SUPPORT ANY OPPOSITION.
SHARE FILE.
WE DON'T HAVE AN APPROVED
POSITION -- BUT WOULD KNOW THE
KELLY EPA ESTIMATES THE COST OF
THIS BILL ARE MINOR AN
OBSERVABLE.
WE DID A SHOW LATE NOTE THAT --
THE BILL MAY RESULT IN UNKNOWN
POTENTIAL LOSSES ASSOCIATED WITH
MISSPENT AND OR MISUSED VANCE
FUNDS TO EXTEND THEIR
UNRECOVERABLE [inaudible]
RESTORE CASH.
WHAT'S THE MAGIC OF THE EIGHT
MONTH PERIOD OF HAVING TO SPEND
ALL THE MONEY ON THE GRANT
WITHIN EIGHT MONTHS.
SO THAT WAS AN AMENDMENT OF IN
ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS SLEEK --
ARE IN DISCUSSIONS WITH THEM THE
FIRST PROPOSED SIX MONTHS OF AND
THEN WAIT WITH DISCUSSIONS WITH
COUNTY PA THEIR PREFERRED THE
EIGHT MONTH -- SO THOUSAND
MOMENT YEAH SO SO INITIALLY --
DE IT WAS IN THE ORIGINAL BILLS --
THE TIME FRAME WAS A YEAR AND SO --
THE APPROPRIATIONS STAFF FELT IT
WAS YOU KNOW MORE EFFICIENT TO
REDUCE IT TO EIGHTY TWO TO EIGHT
MONTHS.
BOTH FOR ACCOUNTABILITY -- YOU
KNOW -- YOU KIND OF GET THE THE
ACCOUNTABILITY OF O OF OF OF
THE FUNDS ARE GOING TO BE
ALLOCATED AND TO REALLY MAKE
SURE THAT -- OF THESE PROJECTS
WERE GOING TO BE YOU KNOW THAT
THAT THE PROJECT APPLICANTS.
WERE WE KNOW WHAT IT HERE -- TO
YOU KNOW THERE ARE -- YOU KNOW
ADVANCE THEY'RE PLANNING WHEN IT
CAME TO THE EXPENSE OF THESE
FUNDS BUT FISCALLY THAT DOESN'T
MAKE ANY SENSE I MEAN YOU'RE
DOING YOU'VE GOT.
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
WORKING ON ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
ISSUES TO ARBITRARILY SAY THAT
YOU HAVE.
TO DO ALL YOUR PLANNING GRANT
WITHIN SIX MONTHS DOESN'T
REFLECT THE WORK THAT'S ON THE
GROUND.
I MEAN HOW WITH THE HOW THE WITH
THE APPROPRIATIONS OTHER THAN
JUST.
BECAUSE YOU'RE WORKING IN
CONJUNCTION WITH ANOTHER
ENVIRONMENTAL FOLKS THEY MAY NOT
BE READY IN SIX MONTHS AND YOU
HAVE YOUR GRANT.
PUSH OR ANY CONSIDERATION FOR
WHAT YOUR PARTNERS BECAUSE
NORMALLY AN ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE GROUP IS PARTNERING WITH
SOME.
ENVIRONMENTAL GROUPS ENGINEERS
TECHNICIANS YET AT THAT.
JUST TO SAY THE GRANT YOU HAVE
TO SPEND ALL YOUR MONEY IN THE
GRANT MAY NOT.
REFLECT REALITY IT WAS NOT THE
WHOLE GRAND -- THAT'S FOR THE
FIRST ARE THE 50% ADVANCE
PAYMENT AND THEN AFTER THAT THE
EIGHT MONTHS THEY'LL HAVE SOME
REPORTING TO DO AND THEN THEY
WOULD.
BE GIVEN AND ANOTHER 50%.
SO IT'S NOT EIGHT MONTHS FOR THE
WHOLE GRANT AMOUNT.
IT'S ONLY 50% OF THE EVENTS
[inaudible]
HI.
IT JUST SEEMS LIKE IN.
I CONDITION THAT SET THàNH TO
PEOPLE THAT TYPICALLY ARE NOT
WELL ORGANIZED AND YOU'RE TRYING
TO REACH OUT TO THIS COMMUNITY
TO GET THEM ORGANIZED TO PUT
ANOTHER CONDITION ON THERE IN
THE APPEARANCE THAT.
THEY'RE GOING TO GET RESULTS --
I I GUESS.
FROM A PHYSICAL POINT OF VIEW I
WOULD I WOULD CAUTION CAL EPA ON
ON LETTING OUT THE MONEY IN
ADVANCE THAT'S WHAT IT SEEMS TO
ME IS THAT.
IT GOES UP 250% SO YOU MIGHT
WANT TO SEE.
HAPPEN LESS MONEY DEPENDING ON
WHAT THE GRANT YES WHICH IS.
YOU KNOW SORT OF DEFEATING WHAT
THE PURPOSE OF THE WHOLE THING
IS BUT I WILL -- LEAVE IT THERE.
DID YOU WANT TO RESPOND AT ALL.
YOU KNOW I THINK -- SO THIS WAS
ADDRESSED AS WELL ON A PREVIOUS
COMMITTEE ND I THINK IT IS A
POINT WELL TAKEN YOU KNOW I
THINK YOU KNOW AS FAR AS THE YOU
KNOW THE TIME MEAN AND YOU KNOW
I WOULD HOPE THAT FOLKS THAT ARE%
PLANNED FOR THESE FUNDS THAT.
YOU KNOW IN PREPARATION AND AND
AND AND APPLY FOR SUCH FUNDS
THAT THEY ANTICIPATE YOU KNOW.
THE TIME FRAME YOU KNOW AND THE
LONGEVITY OF HOW LONG THESE
PROJECTS ARE GOING TO TAKE --
AND SO CERTAINLY -- YOU KNOW I I
YOU KNOW I AGREE IT IS A CONCERN
BUT YOU KNOW CERTAINLY THIS IS
AN OPPORTUNITY TO EXPAND
OPPORTUNITIES BUT AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL FOR THE SMALL
ORGANIZATIONS AND AND THE SMALL
NONPROFITS. TO REALLY MAKE SURE
THAT THESE IMPORTANT BY MIDDLE
JUSTICE ISSUES THAT THERE ARE
YOU KNOW BEING HANDLED -- AS
LOCALLY AS POSSIBLE.
IT WITH THAT THAN ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS SISTER MOTION.
WE HAVE A MOTION.
MY COLLEAGUE HAS EXPRESSED
CONCERNS OBVIOUSLY PLEASE TAKE
ON THE HARD AND ABSOLUTELY
[inaudible]
TRY [inaudible]
TO WHAT.
OKAY HIGHLIGHTED A PROBLEM
[inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
OKAY.
ALL RIGHT WILL TAKE THE ROLE.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
SENATE FLOOR PORTANTINO HI
PORTANTINO AYE BATES.
BATES AYE BRADFORD. TO RAZA.
DORADO AYE HILL HILL AYE JONES.
JONES I WE CASKEY.
CASKET II HI THE BILL IS ON CALL.
AND WE WILL GO TO MISTER LOW I
THINK SLACK IN THE ROOM.
AB.
SEVEN SEVEN NINE TELL US ABOUT
AB SEVEN SEVEN NINE WHICH IS A
TO PASS AND SUPPORT ON BOTH
SIDES THE JURY MUCH RICHER AND
MEMBERS THIS.
ASSISTANT CLOSING A LOOPHOLE
WITH ACUPUNCTURE BOARD INCREASES
ENFORCEMENT RESPECTFULLY ASK
PRIVATE.
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
MAN BUT A CALIFORNIA ACTING
SUPPORT EXECUTIVE OFFICER THE
BOARD TO SUPPORT POSITION
BECAUSE TO BE MINOR AN
OBSERVABLE.
ANY OPPOSITION [inaudible]
SIR FILE.
WE DON'T HAVE AN APPROVED
POSITION -- BUT WE KNOW THAT THE
WORKLOAD TO PROPAGATE PROMULGATE
REGULATIONS AND MAKE SYSTEM
RELATED CHANGES IS EXPECTED TO
BE MINOR AN OBSERVABLE.
ADDITIONALLY ANY LICENSING AND
ENFORCEMENT WORKLOAD FOR THE
BOARD WILL BE OFFSET BY NEW
REVENUES FROM THE FEES PROVIDED
IN THIS BILL -- IN THE BOARD CAN
ABSORB THESE ADDITIONAL COSTS
WITHIN ITS CURRENT EXPENDITURE
AUTHORITY.
ANY QUESTIONS FOR MISTER LOW.
SEEING NONE.
WE HAVE A MOTION MISTER WHAT
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE RECESS
FOR VOTE.
FANTASTIC WE WILL CALL THE VOTE
ON A. B. SEVEN SEVEN NINE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE SENATE
FLOOR PORTANTINO AYE PORTANTINO
AYE BATES.
BATES AYE BRADFORD.
DORADODORADO AYE HILL.
HILL AYE JONES JONES I WE CASKEY.
BECAUSE HE AYE.
THE BILL WAS ON CALL THANK YOU.
THERE ARE NO OTHER AUTHORS IN
THE ROOM WE'RE GOING TO GO BACK.
TO MS QUIRK SILVA A. B. NINE
FORTY SEVEN IS OR ANYBODY IN
SUPPORT OF AB. NINE FORTY SEVEN
TWENTY OPPOSITION AB NINE FORTY
SEVEN IS THERE FILE ON A. B..
NINE FORTY SEVEN AT THIS BILL
COULD CREATE A PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT GENERAL FUND
REIMBURSABLE MANDATE A LIKELY IN
THE LOW HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS TO
LOW MILLIONS OF DOLLARS FOR
SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
ALL RIGHT.
WITHOUT ANY QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION A. B. NINE FORTY SEVEN
GOES TO SUSPENSE.
AB THREE SIXTY NINE MS WEBER CSU
SUPPORT STAFF.
THEIR SUPPORT.
FOR THREE SIXTY NINE THANK YOU
MISTER MEMBERS MITCH SNIDER WITH
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION IN
SUPPORT [inaudible]
SIR OPPOSITION.
IS THERE A FILE.
THE CSU CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE
ESTIMATES COSTS OF APPROXIMATELY
SEVENTY EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS A
TO IMPLEMENT THE BILL'S
PROVISIONS IN THE FIRST YEAR AND
APPROXIMATELY EIGHTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS.
ANNUALLY THEREAFTER -- BECAUSE
THE BILL REQUIRES CSU TO FIND
ITS PROVISIONS WITHIN EXISTING
RESOURCES THE COSTS ASSOCIATED
WITH THIS BILL WOULD LIKELY
DIVERT A COMMENSURATE LEVEL OF
RESOURCES FROM OTHER PROGRAMS.
AND OTHER PURPOSES THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT WITHOUT OBJECTION AB
THREE SIX NINE WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE AB -- FOR FOR MY MISTER
STONE THEIR SUPPORT.
PROPOSITION THEIR FILE.
THE DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER
AFFAIRS ESTIMATES THE BUREAU OF
CANNABIS CONTROL AND KERR ANNUAL
COST OF ONE HUNDRED TWENTY TWO
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN.
TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND ONE
HUNDRED FOURTEEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS BEGINNING IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO FROM THE
CAMPUS CONTROL FUND FOR AN
ADDITIONAL POSITION TO ADDRESS
INCREASED INCREASED WORKLOAD IN
THIS BILL -- THE WORKLOAD FOR
THE BUREAU TO PROMULGATE.
REGULATIONS IS ESTIMATED TO BE
MINOR OBSERVABLE.
OF FINALLY THE DEPARTMENT OF
AGRICULTURE STATES THE CURRENT%
TRACK ENTRY SYSTEM DOESN'T HAVE
THE ABILITY TO UPLOAD A
CORRECTED CERTIFICATE OF
ANALYSIS AND ESTIMATES COST OF
ROUGHLY ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS. TO TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS TO MAKE THE NECESSARY IT
SYSTEM CHANGES.
RIGHT ANY QUESTIONS SEEING NO
QUESTIONS BUT OBJECTION AB FOUR
OH FOUR WITHOUT A SUSPENSE.
MOVIE ON A MISTER MEDINA AB FOR
TWENTY EIGHT SPECIAL EDUCATION
FUNDING.
IS THERE SUPPORT.
KATHY HALL THE CALIFORNIA STATE
PTA IN SUPPORT.
RON WRAPPING PF THE CALIFORNIA
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS AND
SUPPORT.
RUNNING A CODES ASSISTANT
SUPERINTENDENT OF TO HIM A
COUNTY CELL BUT A SUPPORT AND
ALSO ON BEHALF OF STOP
ADMINISTRATORS OF CALIFORNIA
SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING MARIA FERNANDEZ LOU
FROM HERE FROM UPLAND CALIFORNIA
IF I MAY HAVE A COUPLE OF
MINUTES OF THE COMMITTEE'S TIME
MISTER CHAIR I WOULD APPRECIATE
IT FOR MY COMMENTS IN OPPOSITION.
NO ONE SPOKE IN PLAN FOR GIVE
YOU CUP TWO MINUTES SO PLEASE
THANK YOU SO MUCH WE APPRECIATE
IT -- IN YOUR CONSTITUENTS YES
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR YOU'VE
BEEN VERY GRACIOUS.
AND WE APPRECIATE THAT LAST YEAR
THIS BILL DID NOT GO THROUGH IN
THE FORM OF AB THIRTY ONE THIRTY
SIX O'DONNELL -- WE APPRECIATE
MISTER MEDINA US EFFORTS IN.
DEALING WITH THE ISSUE OF THE
BROKEN SYSTEM IN SPECIAL
EDUCATION.
LAST YEAR I GOT ELECTED TO THE
SAN MARINO COUNTY BOARD OF
EDUCATION REPRESENTING FOUR
HUNDRED THOUSAND RESIDENTS.
IN THE AREA BE BUT MOST
IMPORTANTLY I'M A PARENT THAT
HAS BEEN MIRED IN THE SPECIAL
EDUCATION SYSTEM FOR EIGHTEEN
YEARS.
MY DAUGHTER'S CASE WENT ALL THE
WAY TO THE NINTH CIRCUIT AGAINST
UPLAND UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
AND THE WEST IN CELL BLOCK.
AND WE WON THIS YEAR I'M
BEGINNING COURT WITH TWO CASES --
AGAINST THE SELL BY BECAUSE THEY
WILL NOT IMPLEMENT THE DECISION
BY THE UPLAND UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT BOARD.
BUT I'M GONNA TELL YOU WHY IT'S
A BAD FISCAL POLICY TO PASS THIS
BILL IT'S A BLANK CHECK TO THE
CELL BUS.
WITH NO INSURANCE THAT THE
SERVICES WILL GO TO CHILDREN
WITH DISABILITIES AND I'M JUST
GOING TO GIVE YOU A COUPLE OF
QUICK FACTS ABOUT OUR WEST AND
SILVA. TWO HUNDRED AND ELEVEN
MILLION DOLLAR BUDGET. THIRTY
LAWYERS BUT ONLY ONE BEHAVIOR
SPECIALIST FOR TWELVE THOUSAND
STUDENTS THERE'S REAL SUFFERING
IN MY DISTRICT I HELP MANY
PARENTS ON A VOLUNTEER.
THIS BILL WOULD EMPOWER THE
BULLY.
BY FUNDING THEIR EXCESS SPENDING
IN LITIGATION WITH NO
ACCOUNTABILITY PLEASE OPPOSE
FOUR TO EIGHT MEDINA THANK YOU.
OTHERS IN OPPOSITION.
COMMUNITY ADVISORY COMMITTEE.
SALLY MONAGHAN SPECIAL EDUCATION
TEACHER IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU IS THERE.
FIVE YES WE DON'T HAVE AN
APPROVED POSITION -- THIS BILL
CREASE BETWEEN EIGHT HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION AND ONE BILLION
DOLLARS AN ON GOING PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT GENERAL FUND COSTS.
BY PROVIDING ADDITIONAL
SPECIALIZED EDUCATION FUNDING
FOR PRESCHOOL AVERAGE DAILY
ATTENDANCE AND FOR SUPPLEMENTAL
RATE FOR HIGH COST SERVICES FOR
STUDENTS WITH SEVERE
DISABILITIES IN THE TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY FISCAL YEAR.
ADDITIONALLY THIS BILL MAKES A
SPECIAL EDUCATION BASE RATE
INCREASE TO THE NINETY FIFTH
PERCENTILE OF SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
CONTINGENT UPON AN APPROPRIATION
OF RESULT RESULTING IN AN
ESTIMATED EIGHT HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT GENERAL FUND COST
PRESSURE.
BEGINNING IN.
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY FINALLY
THIS BILL CREATES A REIMBURSABLE
STATE MANDATE IN THE LOW
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT GENERAL FUND. FOR
SURPLUS AND SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO
ADJUST THE DECLINING ENROLLMENT
EIGHTY A CALCULATION.
THANK YOU -- BY THE GOVERNOR HAS
NOT SIGNED THE BUDGET YET BUT
THERE'S ABOUT FOUR HUNDRED AND
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS IN THE
BUDGET FOR THREE AND FORTY SIGN
IT.
NOW THERE'S A SIGN IT BUT IN THE
BUDGET THERE'S I THINK FOUR
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS
FOR SPECIAL ED THREE AND FOUR
YEAR OLDS AND THERE'S ANOTHER
HUNDRED AND THINK FIFTY NINE
MILLION DOLLARS IN FOR
EQUALIZATION OF SPECIAL ED SO.
THERE ARE SOME GOOD STEPS --
DEALING WITH SPECIAL ED -- THAT
I AM VERY PROUD OF SO I I
OBVIOUSLY WILL LOOK AT THIS BILL
IS JUST WELL IT'S ON SUSPENSE
BUT CLEARLY SPECIAL ED DID
PRETTY WELL -- IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET SO WE'RE HAPPY ABOUT THAT
WITH THAT WITHOUT OBJECTION A.
B..
FOR TWENTY EIGHT WITH OUR
SUSPENSE I SEE.
WE HAVE AN AUTHOR HERE PLEASE
COMMON UP MISTER BLOOM AND TELL
US ABOUT A. B. QUESTION. EIGHT
OH SIX WHICH IS A DO PASSED WITH
SUPPORT ON BOTH SIDES.
THANK YOU AND A GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS AB EIGHT OF
SIX ASSISTS HOMELESS YOUTH.
WORKING TOWARDS A COLLEGE DEGREE
BY ADDING FORMERLY HOMELESS
YOUTH TO THE LAW SO THAT THEY
CAN HAVE ACCESS TO THE SAME
OPPORTUNITIES AFFORD TO
CURRENTLY HOMELESS STUDENTS.
IN TWENTY SIXTEEN I AUTHORED AB
EIGHT OH ONE THE SUCCESS FOR
HOMELESS YOUTH IN HIGHER
EDUCATION ACT.
WHICH PROVIDED HOMELESS YOUTH
WITH PRIORITY ENROLLMENT IN A
DESIGNATED LIAISON TO HELP
NAVIGATE THE FINANCIAL AID
PROCESS AND THE OTHER AVAILABLE
SUPPORT SERVICES FOR STUDENTS.
EIGHT OH SIX AMEND THE
DEFINITION OF HOMELESS USED TO
INCLUDE YOUTH WHO ARE CURRENTLY
ENROLLED AND VERIFIED IS BEING
HOMELESS AS WELL.
AS ELIMINATE ELIMINATES THE
LOOMING JANUARY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY STATUTORY SUNSET.
THE BILL WILL HAVE MINOR PROP
NINETY EIGHT GENERAL FUND COST
TO CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
CAMPUSES AND MINOR AND
OBSERVABLE FISCAL IMPACTS TO CSU
AND UC CAMPUSES.
CAN LUIS OF THE CALIFORNIA
COALITION FOR YOUTH IS HERE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
GOOD MORNING CAM LEWIS SERVICE
ON THE CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR
YOUTH AND REALLY APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY THIS MORNING -- WE
JUST THINK THIS WILL MAKE IT
EASIER FOR CAMPUSES TO YOU BE
CONSISTENT AND HOW WE TREAT
CURRENT AND FORMER FOSTER YOUTH
AS WELL AS HOW WE TREAT CURRENT
AND FORMER HOMELESS YOUTH. TO
MAKE SURE IT'S APPLICABLE ACROSS
ALL IN SINGLE LESSON SOME
CONFUSION AND KEEP WORKLOAD DOWN
AND CONTINUE THE PARTY
ENROLLMENT THAT SO NEEDED FOR
OUR YOUTH -- TO BE ABLE TO YOU
WORKING GO TO SCHOOL AT THE SAME
TIME.
THANK YOU.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
JUSTIN SELMA COMBAT FOR THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
CHANCES OFFICE IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
ANY OPPOSITION [inaudible]
SHARE FILE.
I YES WE DON'T HAVE AN APPROVED
POSITION BUT AS THE AUTHOR NOTED --
BOTH THE UC OFFICE OF THE
PRESIDENT AND THE CSU
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE REPORT MINOR
OBSERVABLE COSTS.
AND AFTER ACCOUNTING FOR
RESOURCES PROVIDED TO COMMUNITY
COLLEGES TO SUPPORT PORTION
MINTS AND FROM OTHER CATEGORICAL
PROGRAMS -- ANY COSTS ARE
UNLIKELY TO SEE THE COSTA FRESH
HOLD A REQUIRED FOR A
REIMBURSABLE STATE MANDATE.
SINGLE QUESTIONS WHICH LIKE TO
CLOSE I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
ARRIVAL.
BUT THIS IS.
AB EIGHT OH SIX WITH A DO PASS.
WE HAVE A MOTION WILL CALL THE
ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
SENATE FLOOR PORTANTINO AYE
PORTANTINO AYE BATES.
BATES AYE BRADFORD DORADO DORADO
AYE HILL.
HILL AYE JONES.
JONES I WE CASKEY BECAUSE HE I
FOR THE BILLING CALL THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT WE HAVE NO MORE
AUTHORS WE WILL GO BACK TO MR
MEDINA AB.
TEN NINETY EDUCATION WAIVER
CAMPUS BASED FEES AS THEIR
SUPPORT.
IN FAVOR OF SB IF YOU MAY BE TEN
NINETY SPEAKERS NOW OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
FINANCE.
AND THE UC ESTIMATES ATTEND
STUDENTS SYSTEM WIDE WOULD
RECEIVE THE WAIVER -- RESULTING
IN A FOREGONE REVENUES OF
APPROXIMATELY FOURTEEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS -- THAT CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY INDICATES TWENTY SIX
STUDENTS SYSTEM WIDE QUALIFIED
FOR THE WAIVER IN.
TWENTY SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN
EIGHTEEN AND APPROXIMATE ABOUT
FORTY ONE THOUSAND SYSTEM WIDE --
WOULD BE A LOSS IN REVENUE IF
THIS BILL WERE TO BECOME LAW.
OF FINALLY THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES INDICATE THE
FOR GONE -- LOCAL COMMUNITY
COLLEGE REVENUE FROM PROVIDING
THIS WAIVER -- WOULD BE MINOR
OBSERVABLE.
ALL RIGHT IS THERE ARE ANY
QUESTIONS SEEING NONE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION AB TEN NINETY
WILL GO TO SUSPENSE SO WE HAVE
ONE TWO BILLS LEFT THAT ARE DUE
PASS.
MR MAYS AND MINE RIGHT RIVER
MURATSUCHI IN SCHOOL FOREVER
MARCIA CHEN CELLS OKAY I'M GONNA
JUST KEEP POWER IN THROUGH.
THE MISTER BRADFORD GETS HERE AB
FOUR FIVE SIX BY MR CHIU.
PUBLIC CONTRACTS THERE ANYBODY
IN SUPPORT.
ANYBODY IN OPPOSITION.
SIR FINANCE A YES WE DON'T HAVE
AN APPROVED POSITION BUT WE KNOW
THAT THIS BILL WILL POTENTIALLY
RESULTING CONTINUED -- HIGHER
PROJECT COST BOTH STATE AND
LOCAL AGENCIES.
SEEING NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB FOR FIFTY SIX WILL
GO TO SUSPENSE.
AB NINE FORTY THREE STUDENT.
EQUITY AND ACHIEVEMENT THEIR
SUPPORT.
OPPOSITION SIR FILE.
A YES WE DON'T HAVE AN APPROVED
POSITION -- BUT THIS BILL IS NOT
EXPECTED TO CREATE ADDITIONAL
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT GENERAL
FUND KOSTER COST PRESSURES.
AS THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE HAS
ALREADY ISSUED GUIDANCE
INDICATING THE DISTRICTS MAY
SPEND THEIR SCA FUNDING TO
SUPPORT STUDENTS -- IN FINANCIAL
DISTRESS.
SEEING NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB NINE FORTY THREE
WE'RE GONNA SUSPENSE ACR FIFTY
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT MISTER
CHIU.
SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT.
ANDREA RIVERA ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT POLICY
CENTER WHERE THE CO SPONSORS OF
THIS RESOLUTION AND IN STRONG
SUPPORT [inaudible]
ANY OPPOSITION.
FINANCE THE FILE NO FILE SEEING
NO QUESTIONS ACR FIFTY WILL GO
TO SUSPENSE.
AB SIX ELEVEN BY MISTER NAZARIAN
SEXUAL ABUSE.
OF ANIMALS. FOR ANYBODY IN
SUPPORT.
SORRY OPPOSITION.
IS THERE A FILE.
WE DON'T HAVE AN APPROVED
POSITION -- BUT TO THE EXTENT
THIS BILL ADDS TO THE TRIAL
COURTS CASELOAD OF COURT
BACKLOGS MAY INCREASE AND COULD
CREATE PRESSURE ON THE GENERAL
FUND. TO HANDLE THE INCREASED
WORKLOAD.
OF HOWEVER WE KNOW THE COURTS
DON'T TYPICALLY RECEIVE FUNDING
ON A WORKLOAD BASIS OTHER FOR
LESS THIS PARTICULAR CASE WOULD
BECOME SIGNIFICANT AND CAN BE
DOCUMENTED.
IT IS LIKELY TO BE ABSORBED.
ADDITIONALLY BY REQUIRING COUNTY
MENTAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS
PROVIDING COUNSELING AT THEIR
EXPENSE ON TO SPECIFIED
INDIVIDUALS THIS BILL
POTENTIALLY INCLUDES GENERAL
FUND COST PRESSURES PURSUANT TO
PROPOSITION.
THIRTY THE MAN OF WHICH IS
UNKNOWN.
SEEING NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION.
SB SIX ELEVEN WE'LL GO TO
SUSPENSE IS GONZALEZ FLETCHER AB
FIVE HUNDRED SCHOOL EMPLOYEES.
MATERNITY LEAVE US YOUR SUPPORT.
WHICH DUGGAR WITH CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION IN SUPPORT.
OKAY IS THERE OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
SIR FILE.
YES AT THIS BILL WILL CREATE
SIGNIFICANT COSTS FOR LOCAL
EDUCATION AGENCIES TO PROVIDE AT
LEAST SIX WEEKS OF PAID LEAVE --
IF 1% OF CATER FOURTEEN
EMPLOYEES TAKE THE LEAP PROPOSED
BY THIS BILL.
I AGENCIES COULD INCUR COSTS OF
TWENTY MILLION TO FORTY EIGHT
DOLLARS -- AND IN ADDITION TO
THE COST PROVIDING PAID LEAVE A
AGENCIES WILL LIKELY AND KERR
SUBSTITUTE EMPLOYEES COSTS IN
THE MILLIONS OF DOLLARS FOR THE
PERIOD THAT APPLICABLE EMPLOYEES
ARE ON LEAVE.
AS A RESULT OF THE BENEFITS
PROVIDED BY THIS BILL.
FINALLY THE BILL COULD CREATE A
REIMBURSABLE STATE MANDATE THAT
COULD COST TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
DOLLARS PROPOSITION NINETY
GENERAL FUND.
BY REQUIRING THE GOVERNING BOARD
OF THE SCHOOL DISTRICT -- AND
COMMUNITY COLLEGE TO ADOPT RULES
AND REGULATIONS.
ARE THERE QUESTIONS SEEING NONE
WITHOUT OBJECTION AB.
FIVE HUNDRED WILL GO TO SUSPENSE
MR BERMAN AB.
FIVE THIRTY EIGHT A SEXUAL
ASSAULT IS THERE ANYONE IN FAVOR.
MAYBE FIVE THIRTY EIGHT ANY
OPPOSITION SERRA FILE.
A FINANCE NOTES THAT ADDITIONAL
COSTS RELATED TO REIMBURSEMENT
SETTING AND CHANGES TWO FORMS ME --
INCUR COSTS TO THE CALIFORNIA
OFFICE OF EMERGENCY SERVICES.
IN ADDITION TO THE EXTENT
FEDERAL GRANT FUNDS FOR THIS
PURPOSE ARE REDUCED OR
ELIMINATED IN FUTURE YEARS.
A THESE REQUIREMENTS -- COULD
CREATE ADDITIONAL PRESSURE ON
THE GENERAL FUND TO CONTINUE
THIS LEVEL SUPPORT.
A AND ALL THAT LASTLY ALTHOUGH
IT IS STILL TO BE DETERMINED WE
KNOW THAT ADDITIONAL STANDARDS
IMPOSED ON THE CLINICS AND
EMERGENCY MEDICAL HILL
FACILITIES.
MAY RESULT IN INCREASED GENERAL
FUND COSTS TO THE MEDICAL
PROGRAM.
SEEING NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB FIVE THIRTY ABLE
GONNA SUSPENSE MOVING ANIMIST
SMITH -- AB FIVE FORTY THREE
EDUCATION SEXUAL HARASSMENT.
THEIR SUPPORT.
FOR EIGHTY FIVE FORTY THREE
PROPOSITION THEIR FILE.
THIS BILL COULD CREATE A
REIMBURSABLE STATE MANDATE AND
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT GENERAL
FUND FOR SCHOOLS TO MEET THE
REQUIREMENTS OF THIS BILL.
SEEN NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB FIVE FORTY THREE
WITHOUT A SUSPENSE AB.
SIXTEEN THIRTY SEVEN ON
UNCLAIMED PROPERTY IS THERE
SUPPORT SIR OPPOSITION IS THERE
FILE. TO THE EXTENT THE
PROPERTIES RETURNED DIRECTLY TO
STATE AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS THIS
BILL WOULD REDUCE THE POTENTIAL
pOTHERWISE BE USED BY THE STATE
UNTIL THE RESOURCES ARE CLEANED.
SEEING NO QUESTION WITHOUT
OBJECTION A. B. SIXTEEN THIRTY
SEVEN WE GOT A SUSPENSE.
AB FIVE FOUR FIVE MISTER LOW ON
CANNABIS CONTROL.
THEIR SUPPORT.
PROPOSITION SIR FILE.
I GIVEN THE SMALL NUMBER STAFF
OF THE APPEALS PANEL AND THE
SIGNIFICANT WORKLOAD ASSOCIATED
WITH SUNSET REVIEW.
OF THE PANEL WILL LIKELY NOT BE
ABLE TO ABSORB THE INCREASED
WORKLOAD AND WILL LIKELY REQUIRE
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES.
AT THE BUREAU OF CANNABIS
CONTROL INDICATES THIS BILLS ON
ANTICIPATED TO HAVE A FISCAL
IMPACT.
HOWEVER -- WE NOTE THAT DUE --
TO THE THIS COULD IMPACT THE
BUREAU'S ABILITY TO TIMELY
COMPLETE IT'S NORMAL WORKLOAD.
SIGNAL QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB FIVE FOUR FIVE
WILSHIRE SPENCE A. B..
THIRTEEN TWELVE COLLEGE
CONSULTANT ACT MR LOW SIR
SUPPORT.
SIR OPPOSITION IS THEIR FILE.
THE SECRETARY OF STATE INDICATES
THAT THE LEGISLATIVE INTENT
LANGUAGE IN THIS BILL -- TO HAVE
THE SECRETARY IMPLEMENT THE
REPORTING AND TRACKING PROCESS
WITHIN ONE YEAR OF MAKING THE
REQUIRED RECOMMENDATION TO THE
LEGISLATURE IS NOT FEASIBLE.
ADDITIONALLY THE SECRETARY OF
STATE ESTIMATES OF THE COST OF
TWO POINT NINE MILLION DOLLARS
IN THE FIRST YEAR -- AND ONE
POINT NINE MILLION DOLLARS
ANNUALLY ON GOING --
ADDITIONALLY THE DEPARTMENT OF
CONSUMER AFFAIRS ESTIMATES THAT
THE BUREAU OF PRIVATE
POSTSECONDARY EDUCATION WILL
INCUR COSTS OF APPROXIMATELY ONE
HUNDRED FIFTY FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS AND SPECIAL FUND.
IN TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO A TO
ESTABLISH AND SUPPORT THE TASK
FORCE AND DEVELOP THE REPORT TO
THE LEGISLATURE REQUIRED BY THIS
BILL.
SINGLE QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION A. B. THIRTEEN TWELVE
AGO TO SUSPENSE MOVING TO MISS
CORREOS BILLS.
AB FIVE FIVE SIX OUTDOOR
EXPERIENCES COMMUNITY ACCESS --
THERE'S SOMEONE HERE IN SUPPORT
OF FIVE FIVE SIX IS THEIR
OPPOSITION IS THEIR FILE.
THE NATURAL RESOURCES AGENCY
ESTIMATES THIS BILL WILL REQUIRE
ONE POSITION AND ONE HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS GENERAL
FUND ANNUALLY. TO ADMINISTER THE
PROGRAM.
HOWEVER -- WE WE KNOW THAT THE
SYSTEM IS LIKELY LOW AS IT ONLY
TAKES INTO ACCOUNT THE
ADMINISTRATION OF SUCH A PROGRAM
ON THE NOT THE COST OF PROVIDING
THE INCREASED COMMUNITY ACCESS.
ADDITIONALLY WE WOULD KNOW THE
BILL DOESN'T SPECIFY A FUN
SOURCE FOR THE REQUIRED PROGRAM.
SEEING NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB FIVE FIVE SIX WILL
GO TO SUSPENSE.
AB -- SIXTEEN FIFTY EIGHT
CARILLO ON TEACHER CREDENTIALING
SIR SUPPORT.
OPPOSITION THEIR FILE.
THE COMMISSION ON TEACHER
CREDENTIALING ESTIMATES ONE TIME
COSTS OF TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS FROM THE TEACHER
CREDENTIALS FUND. FOR THE
COMMISSION TO CONVENE THE
SPECIFIED WORKGROUP REIMBURSE
TRAVEL EXPENSES AND PRODUCED A
REPORT TO THE LEGISLATURE.
SEEING NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION A. B. SIXTEEN FIFTY
EIGHT WITH A SUSPENSE AB SEVEN
TWENTY OFFICE OF PLANNING AND
RESEARCH IS THEIR SUPPORT
OPPOSITION.
FILE THE OFFICE OF PLANNING AND
RESEARCH ESTIMATES COSTS OF
APPROXIMATELY NINETY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND FOR STAFFING
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS AND TRAVEL
EXPENSES.
SEEING NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB SEVENTEEN TWENTY
WILL GO TO SUSPENSE.
MOVING TO MISTER MAIENSCHEIN AB
FIVE SIX FIVE ON PUBLIC HEALTH
WORKFORCE LOANS THEIR SUPPORT.
PROPOSITION SIR FILE.
YES WE ARE OPPOSED TO THIS
MEASURE BECAUSE IT IMPOSES ON
OUR SPENT A NEW UNFUNDED
WORKLOAD AND WOULD INCREASE COST
PRESSURES ON AN ALREADY
OVERSUBSCRIBED PROGRAM.
SEEING NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB FIVE SIXTY FIVE
WILL GO TO SUSPENSE AB SIX
FOURTEEN BY MISS EGGMAN INCOME
TAX.
CREDITS FOOD BANKS IS THEIR
SUPPORT OPPOSITION FILE.
THE FRANCHISE TAX BOARD
ESTIMATES TOTAL GENERAL FUND
REVENUE LOSSES OF TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY FOUR HUNDRED
TWENTY ONE AND TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN.
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO OF THE
BOARD ESTIMATES THIS BILL WOULD
NOT SIGNIFICANTLY INCREASE THIRD
MINISTRY OF COSTS.
SINGLE QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION AV SIX FOURTEEN MY
MISSING ONE WILL GO THE SUSPENSE
LIVING ON THAT AB EIGHT FORTY
EIGHT BY MR GRAY MEDI CAL.
CONTINUOUS GLUCOSE MONITORS AS
THEIR SUPPORT.
OPPOSITION FILE.
YES I WE'RE OPPOSED TO THIS BILL
BECAUSE IT ALLOCATE SIGNIFICANT
GENERAL FUND RESOURCES THAT
SHOULD BE CONSIDERED WITH OTHER
PRIORITIES TO THE ANNUAL BUS
BUDGET PROCESS -- THE DEPARTMENT
OF HEALTH CARE SERVICES
ESTIMATES A COST OF ONE HUNDRED
POINT MILLION DOLLARS A TOTAL
FUNDS THIRTY ONE POINT NINE
MILLION WHAT YOUR GENERAL FUND
IN THE FIRST YEAR.
AND NINETY TWO POINT SEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS ON GOING TWENTY
NINE POINT FOUR MILLION DOLLARS
OF WHICH ARE GENERAL FUND --
ADDITIONALLY THE DEPARTMENT OF
MANAGED HEALTHCARE INDICATES NO
FISCAL IMPACT WITH THIS BILL.
RIGHT SAY NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB EIGHT FORTY EIGHT
WILL GO TO SUSPENSE.
AB EIGHT EIGHT FIVE I MISS OR
WHEN PROPERTY TAXATION NEW
CONSTRUCTION.
OR ANYONE HERE IN SUPPORT OF AB.
EIGHT EIGHT FIVE TWENTY
OPPOSITION EIGHT EIGHT FIVE IS
THERE FILE.
THE BOARD OF EQUALIZATION
ESTIMATES THIS BILL WOULD REDUCE
ANNUAL PROPERTY TAX REVENUES BY
AS MUCH AS EIGHT HUNDRED AND
TWENTY DOLLARS PER REPLACEMENT
HOME.
AND BY AS MUCH AS FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS PER COMMERCIAL
REPLACEMENT PROPERTY.
ASSUMING HALF A PROPERTY TAX
REVENUE CRUZ DECATUR FOURTEEN
SCHOOLS THAT ALSO BE PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT GENERAL FUND COSTS
AS WELL.
WE KNOW THAT THIS BILL DOES NOT
REPRESENT A DECREASE IN CURRENT
PROPERTY TAX REVENUE BUT
REPRESENTS THE FORFEITURE OF
FUTURE REVENUE GROWTH.
SEEING NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB EIGHT EIGHT FIVE
OVER THE SUSPENSE MISTER SALAS.
YOUR HERE PLEASE COME TELL US
ABOUT AB TWO THREE NINE ON
COMMUNITY COLLEGE NURSING
PROGRAMS THIS IS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION WOULD SUPPORT ON
BOTH SIDES.
I WAS ABOUT.
TO THIRTY NINE THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR THANK YOU -- SENATORS 8%
BEFORE YOU SOME LEGAL TO THIRTY
NINE WOULD EXTEND THE SUNSET ON
CURRENT LAW TO ALLOW CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGE NURSING
PROGRAMS. TO UTILIZE THE MULTI
CAR TO YOUR SCREENING TOOL FOR
ADMISSIONS THE MULTI.
CRITERIA SCREENING TOOL ALLOWS
NURSING PROGRAMS TO ADDRESS THE
IMPACT ON MISSIONS BY ASSISTING
A CANDIDATE'S QUALIFICATIONS AND
DECREASING ATTRITION RATES.
BY ENSURING THAT ENTRANCE OF THE
PROGRAM ARE ADEQUATELY PREPARED
TO UNDERTAKE THE COURSE
REQUIREMENTS.
THAT MEMBERS WE KNOW THAT A LOT
OF THE NURSING PROGRAMS ARE
IMPACTED THIS IS A TOOL THAT A
LOT OF THE COLLEGES ARE USING SO
THAT WE COULD HAVE -- YOU
ACTUALLY UTILIZE ALL THOSE ALL
THOSE SPOTS AND HAVE HIGHER
GRADUATION RATES IN THESE
NURSING PROGRAMS ESPECIALLY WITH
IT BEING SO IMPACTED.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
NINETY HAVE TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT.
PLEASE.
JUSTIN SELMA COMBAT FOR THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
BOARD OF GOVERNORS SPONSOR OF AB.
TWO THIRTY NINE A SPOT IN THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE NURSING
PROGRAM REPRESENTS A SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENT GIVEN THAT THE
STUDENT PAYS FORTY SIX DOLLARS
PER UNIT BUT THE ACTUAL COSTS AS
MUCH GREATER.
OF AB TWO THIRTY NINE WILL
EXTEND THE MULTI CRITERIA
SCREENING PROCESS FOR A FEW MORE
YEARS OF ALL THE ATTRITION RATES
CONTINUE ON THEIR DOWNWARD TREND
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUE
WORKING ON IT.
THANK YOU.
THE OTHERS SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT.
ANY OPPOSITION FINANCE I WOULD
NEUTRALIZE MEASURE.
WE HAVE A MOTION ON THE BILL I
REMEMBER WHEN THOSE.
CRITERIA PUT IN PLACE WAS QUITE
CONTROVERSIAL AT THE TIME THERE
WAS LOTS OF DISCUSSION -- TEN
YEARS LATER IT'S WORKING.
YES OUR LAST REPORT SHOW THAT
THERE IS A PRETTY SIGNIFICANT
DROP AN ATTRITION RATES AND THAT
WAS THE WHOLE POINT IS THAT WE
WERE.
BEFORE THERE WAS CRITERIA THOSE
SLOTS WERE BEING FILLED AND THEN
UNFORTUNATE STUDENTS COULDN'T.
FINISH.
AND BECOME NURSES AND IT WAS
COSTING LOTS OF MONEY AND BEING
OF AN EFFECTIVE SELF.
THANK YOU.
FOR TAKING UP THE MANTLE I KNOW
IT'S CONTROVERSIAL BUT I THINK
IT MAKES SENSE TO HAVE STUDENTS.
ACTUALLY SUCCEED IN IN THE
SYSTEM SO THANK YOU -- ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR ANYTHING WITH THAT
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
AWESOME WILL TAKE THE VOTE.
POURTANT THE MOTION IS TO PASS
TO THE SENATE FLOOR PORTANTINO
AYE PORTANTINO AYE BATES.
BATES AYE BRADFORD TO RAZA.
THANK DORADO AYE HILL.
HELLO I JONES.
JONES I WE CASKEY.
WE CASKEY AYE.
BUT I ALSO CALLED THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
WE DON'T HAVE MR.
MURATSUCHI SO WE'LL GO BACK. TWO
AB EIGHT NINE THREE BY MR GLORIA.
DEL MAR FAIRGROUNDS IS THERE
ANYBODY IN SUPPORT OF EIGHT NINE
THREE THEIR OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
TO EIGHT NINE THREE THE COMMON.
THE CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
TEMPERATURES REPRESENTING GUN
OWNERS CALIFORNIA AND ALSO ON
BEHALF OF THE NATIONAL RIFLE
ASSOCIATION HERE.
IN OPPOSITION TO AB -- EIGHT
NINE THREE GIVEN THAT A FEDERAL
JUDGE A JUDGE KATHY BEEN SERVING
GO -- ISSUED AN ORDER DECLARING
THAT THE THE BAN ON THE GUN
SHOWS AT THAT DEL MAR WERE.
BURKE WERE.
NOT LEGAL THEY'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE THE CASE WE THINK THAT --
THE PRUDENT THING FISCALLY FOR
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA DO IS TO
SUSPEND THIS BILL MAYBE PUT OR
OVER FOR TO YOU -- MAKE IT A TO
YOUR BILL OR TO WAIT TO SEE WHAT
THE COURT SAYS.
BECAUSE THIS -- A JUDGE WAS
APPOINTED BY PRESIDENT OBAMA --
RIGHT AFTER THE THE THE
TESTIMONY ON ON THIS ISSUE.
ISSUED THIS RULING AND SAID THAT --
THIS IS THE STATE CANNOT IMPOSE
THAT KIND OF A BAN ON THE GUN
SHOWS AT DEL MAR SO.
BEING FISCALLY PRUDENT WE HOPE
THAT YOU WILL KEEP THIS BILL IN
COMMITTEE.
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS ROY
GRIFFIS BECOME ABOUT THE
CALIFORNIA RIFLE AND PISTOL
ASSOCIATION.
THIS BILL COMES AT A CRITICAL
TIME IN CALIFORNIA'S FACING A
MASSIVE DECLINE IN HUNTERS AND
FISHERMEN THROW CALIFORNIA SHOWS
LIKE THE DEL MAR SHORE CRITICAL
FOR THE PUBLIC HAVE ACCESS NOT
ONLY. TO IMPLEMENT USED FOR
SPORTING GOODS.
HUNTING AND FISHING BUT ALSO FOR
THE TRAINING SHOWS DON'T TO SELL
ARMS TEY PROVIDE CRITICAL
TRAINING ACCESS TO EDUCATION.
THAT'S CRITICAL FOR GETTING OUR
FOLKS OUT IN THE FIELD.
HUNTING LICENSE HUNTERS IN
CALIFORNIA DECLINE FROM OVER
CENTER SEVERAL THOUSAND IN THE
SEVENTIES TO LESS THAN THREE
HUNDRED THOUSAND A DAY.
FISHERMAN FISHERMAN IN
CALIFORNIA GONE FROM OVER A
MILLION TO TWO MILLION TO LESS
THAN ONE MILLION NOW IN
CALIFORNIA.
AT THE SAME TIME THE POPULATION
HAS GONE UP SIXTY SOME PERCENT
IN THE SAME TIME PERIOD.
SO THE SHOWS ARE CRITICAL NOT
JUST FOR FARM CELLS BUT ACCESS
TO THE IMPLEMENTS OF FOLKS NEED
TO GET OUT AND WRECKED RATE IN
OUR BEAUTIFUL OUTDOORS.
SO AS OF MY COLLEAGUE ALSO SAID
WITH THE LOSS TO PIN AND
EVERYTHING IT'S JUST NOT
FISCALLY RESPONSIBLE -- TO TO
KEEP THIS THIS BILL GOING RIGHT
NOW THAT'S BEEN VETOED NUMEROUS
PRIOR TIMES THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME.
ALL RIGHT SIR FILE.
YES WE DON'T HAVE AN APPROVED
PHYSICIAN ON THIS BILL BUT
ACCORDING TO DATA FROM THE BOARD
OF DIRECTORS MEETING OF FOR THE
DEL MAR FAIRGROUNDS.
IT'S GOING SHOWS OF RESULTED IN
NET REVENUES OF APPROXIMATELY
THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS
IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN AND A
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
IN.
TWENTY EIGHTEEN THIS BILL WOULD
LIKELY ELIMINATE THIS REVENUE
UNLESS THE DISTRICT AG
ASSOCIATION IS ABLE TO REPLACE
THE EVENT WITH OTHERS THAT
GENERATE SIMILAR LEVELS LEVELS
OF REVENUE.
BERLIN YES THERE ARE TWO MORE
BILLS THAT ARE DUE PASS -- THREE
THREE ACTUALLY -- SELECT.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS ON THIS
WITHOUT OBJECTION -- AB EIGHT
NINETY THREE WILL GO TO SUSPENSE.
MISSTATES THE 1% THAT BILLS.
FULL.
SHOT IT.
HIS QUESTIONS WERE WE CAN WAIT.
YOU WANNA GO FIRST WE'RE GOING
TO DO THE PLAN SURE I'LL GO TO
THE CLAIMS.
I'M SORRY THROUGH THE AIR.
I'M NOT BOTHERED WITH.
THE YEAR OF THE FAITHFUL
[inaudible]
YEAH YEAH [inaudible]
WHAT THE VICTIMS COMPENSATION
BOARD FOR THE PAYMENT OF FIVE
STATE CLAIMS RELATED TO THE
AROUNDHIS CONVICTION OF MARCO
CONTRARIES MANUAL CRISTINA LOPEZ?
DASH ONE READ -- HORSE ROBERTS
AND TIMOTHY ATKINS IN EACH OF
THESE CASES THE COURT SET ASIDE
THE CONVICTIONS AND MADE A
FINDING OF FACTUAL INNOCENCE.
EXISTING LAW REQUIRES THE BOARD
TO RECOMMEND AN APPROPRIATION TO
COVER THESE CLAIMS WITHOUT A
HEARING.
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE HAS
APPROVED THE PAYMENTS OF THESE
CLAIMS I'VE HAD AND I HAVE NEIL
AND THIS.
FROM THE VICTIMS COMPENSATION
BOARD HERE TO ANSWER QUESTIONS
[inaudible]
GO AHEAD.
AND MR ANNA YES GOOD MORNING
NEIL IN THIS WITH THE VICTIM
COMPENSATION BOARD HERE TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
REVELATION I'D LIKE TO ASK A
QUESTION REGARDING.
THE COUNTRY -- OF CASE AND HELP
US UNDERSTAND HOW THIS GENTLEMAN
NOW SPENT THAT MANY YEARS
KNOWING THAT HE WAS INNOCENT.
AND WE DIDN'T COUNT.
DID HE NOTHING CAME FORWARD
EIGHTY ACTUALLY HAD AND NOW A
LETTER FROM THIS JOURNEY NOT.
THAT SEEMS TO BE IN [inaudible]
L. COUNTERINTUITIVE.
OF GET A LITTLE MORE INFORMATION
FOR US SO WE CAN PUT ON THE
RECORD.
THAT'S CORRECT HE DID NOT FILE --
FOR HIDEOUS RELIEF.
WHEN HE FOUND OUT THE
INFORMATION -- INTO THE PENAL
CODE -- BOARD COULD NOT CONSIDER
THAT AS A FACTOR FOR
COMPENSATION HE DID HAVE A
FINDING OF FACTUAL INNOCENCE.
OF THE DA STIPULATED TO IS
FACTUAL INNOCENCE ON THE CHARGES
AND SO THE FOR THE BOARD IS
MANDATED TO RECOMMEND
COMPENSATION.
I'M I'M ASSUMING THAT THERE WAS
NO INFORMATION THAT WAS
FORTHCOMING TO YOU OR
CORRECTIONS OVER THE IS AN AND
ABOUT NINETEEN YEARS EVEN THOUGH
WE HAD A LETTER FROM HIS
ATTORNEY.
THAT NONE OF THAT WAS EVER.
FORTHCOMING.
I DON'T BELIEVE IT WAS EXPLAINED
ANY FURTHER -- HEAD WAS ON THE
RECORD THAT HE WAS INFORMED BY A
DETECTIVE IN NINETEEN NINETY
THAT THERE MAY BE EXCULPATORY
EVIDENCE REGARDING ANOTHER.
POSSIBLE THE SHOOTER AND HE DID
NOT ACT ON THAT.
INFORMATION [inaudible]
UNTIL LATER.
WELL I THINK THE SITUATION WE
HAVE RIGHT NOW IDEAS WITH IDEAS
BUT I I REALLY THINK THAT THERE
SHOULD BE SOMETHING ON THE
COMPENSATION BOARD THAT TAKES A
LOOK AT OUT TO ISSUES.
LIKE THIS THAT MIGHT MERE THE
SAME SITUATION BECAUSE THAT
PARTICULAR OBJECT TO WHO
PROVIDED THAT INFORMATION THERE
SHOULD HAVE BEEN SOME CROSS.
REFERENCING WITHOUT.
THE CORRECTIONS AND WITH A BIG
SOME CON COMPENSATION BOARD
BECAUSE THE TAXPAYERS ARE PAYING
FOR AN INDIVIDUAL WHO COULD HAVE
BEEN RELEASED AND SHOULD HAVE
BEEN RELEASED FRANKLY MANY YEARS
AGO SO.
IT'S ONE TO HAVE THAT ON THE
RECORD.
ARE ANY OTHER OF INDIVIDUALS IN
SUPPORT.
MANY FOLKS IN OPPOSITION.
FINANCES IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE THE
CLASS FOR AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
MADAM SECRETARY CULTURAL
[inaudible]
PORTANTINO AYE PORTANTINO AYE
BATES AYE BATES AYE BRADFORD.
TORONTO.
TORONTO AYE HILL HILL AYE JONES
JONES I WE CASKEY.
CASKEY AYE.
WELL MISS RATES IS GOING. TO FOR
MAYES AND THEN WE HAVE --
MURATSUCHI RIGHT.
AND THAT BILL IS ON CALL
[inaudible]
ALL RIGHT YES.
THANK YOU ARE CHAIR US LOOK FOR
ALLOWING ME 2% TODAY ON BEHALF
OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER MAYES.
BY EIGHTY TEN EIGHTY FOUR WOULD
ALLOW INDIAN WELLS LE QUITA AND
THE YOLO HOUSING AUTHORITY TO
DEVELOP A CAPITAL RESERVE USING
THEIR EXCESS FUNDS.
THE FUNDS COME FROM THE FORMER
REDEVELOPMENT AGENCIES LOW AND
MODERATE INCOME ASSET FUN
CURRENT LAW ALLOWS THE FUNDS TO
BE RESERVED FOR FOUR YEARS.
THIS BILL WOULD SIMPLY EXTEND
THAT TIME LINE TO EIGHT YEARS
AND WITH ME MORNING OF MISTER
GONZALEZ G. SON WHO WILL.
I ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS AND MAYBE
ELABORATE A BIT.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS CHASING AND SALAS
REPRESENTING THE CITIES OF
LOOKING TO AN INDIAN WELLS THE
AUTHOR DID A GREAT JOB QUICK
STUDY ON ON THE ISSUE -- THIS
JUST ALLOWS THE COMMUNITIES THAT
I AM VERY FEW ACTUALLY BECAME
HOUSING SUCCESSORS TO RETAIN --
ACCESS SURPLUS FUNDS IN ORDER TO
MORE CRITICALLY NEEDED AND
LARGER INFRASTRUCTURE
IMPROVEMENTS AND WITH THAT I'M
HAPPY ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THANK
YOU [inaudible]
THIS IS.
SIGNAL QUESTIONS -- RESTORE
CASSIE IS THERE A MOTION.
WE HAVE WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
IF I CAN GET FINALLY MEMBER
MAYES I ASKED FOR AN AYE VOTE
THANK YOU AND WE'LL HEAR FROM
FINANCE.
WE DON'T HAVE AN APPROVED
POSITION ON THIS BILL AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT --
ESTIMATE A MINOR OBSERVABLE
IMPACT ASSOCIATED WITH THIS BILL.
WE WOULD ISSUE ONLY NOTE THAT
THIS BILL COULD POTENTIALLY
RESULT IN LESS EXCESS SURPLUS
FUNDS THAT TRANSFER TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF FOR VARIOUS
HOUSING PROGRAMS THANK YOU.
RIGHT WITH THAT WILL TAKE.
THE VOTE.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
SENATE FLOOR PORTANTINO AYE
PORTANTINO AYE BATES AYE BATES
BY BRADFORD. TO RAZA DORADO AYE
HILL HILL AYE JONES.
JONES I WE CASKEY.
WE CASKEY AYE.
SO THAT BILL IS OUT AND IT'S ON
CALL.
WE'RE GOING TO GO TO HAVE NO
OTHER.
MARCH WHICH IS ON HIS WAY.
WE'LL GO TO AB EIGHT NINETY
EIGHT BY MS WICKS.
CHILDREN'S BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
ACTION IS THEIR SUPPORT.
WE DON'T HAVE.
A CODES ASSISTANT SUPERINTENDENT
OF TO HIM A COUNTY STOP US
SUPPORT AND ON BEHALF OF SELF
ADMINISTRATORS OF CALIFORNIA.
WE ARE WERE A SUPPORT IF AMENDED
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR HER
AMENDMENTS AND ARE NOW SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE IS THERE FILE FILE
NO FILE SEE NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB.
EIGHT NINETY EIGHT IS GOING THE
SUSPENSE MOVING AN A. B. ELEVEN
EIGHTY MINUTES FRIEDMAN WATER
RECYCLED WATER.
THEIR SUPPORT.
IS THERE [inaudible]
TWENTY SEVEN WE DIDN'T.
A WITHOUT ELEVEN TWENTY SEVEN I
MISSED.
WE'RE GONNA LET'S DO WHAT SINCE
I STARTED A LEVIN EIGHTY SIR
SUPPORTERS ARE OPPOSITION --
FILE FILE.
NO FILE -- NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION ELEVEN EIGHTY WILL GO
TO SUSPENSE -- MISTER MURATSUCHI
COM TELL US ABOUT YOUR BILL.
AND THEN WE'LL GO BACK.
TO ELEVEN TWENTY SEVEN THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIRMAN
SENATORS.
I AM HERE TO PRESENT.
ASSEMBLY BILL.
THREE FOUR TWO NO WHICH IS OUR
EFFORTS.
TO FIGHT BACK AGAINST THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION'S.
ANNOUNCEMENT TO OPEN FEDERAL THE
PROTECTED LANDS. FOR NEW OIL AND
GAS DEVELOPMENT -- THESE WOULD
INCLUDE FEDERAL PROTECTED LANDS.
ON PLACES LIKE THE WILD FLOWER
RIDGE CARILLO.
ABOUT PLANES KARIZ A PLANE
NATIONAL MONUMENT AS WELL AS
POTENTIALLY THE GIANT SEQUOIA
NATIONAL MONUMENT.
THIS IS AN APPROACH THAT.
WE HAVE.
DONE BEFORE JUST LAST YEAR WAS
CENTER JACKSON AS WELL AS MYSELF
WE TEAMED UP. TO FIGHT BACK
AGAINST THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION'S PLAN TO EXPAND.
OFFSHORE OIL DRILLING -- BY L. --
PROHIBITING ANY NEW
INFRASTRUCTURE TO BUILT ON ****
ON STATE LANDS AND SO -- WE ASK
FOR SUPPORT [inaudible]
THIS.
A GOOD AFTERNOON OR GOOD MORNING
TURN MEMBERS NIKITA CRUDDY BUT
THE NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL HERE TODAY IN SUPPORT OF
AB.
THREE FORTY TWO SINCE APRIL THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION IS RELEASE
PLANS TO OPEN UP ONE POINT SEVEN
MILLION ACRES OF PUBLIC LAND AND
MINERALS STATE ADMINISTERED BY
THE FEDERAL BE A LAMB -- BUREAU
OF LAND MANAGEMENT CALIFORNIA TO
OIL DRILLING AND FRACKING ENDING
THE FEDERAL MORATORIUM ON
LEASING CALIFORNIA'S FELT
FEDERAL PUBLIC LANDS OIL
COMPANIES.
BUT IT'S BEEN IN EFFECT FOR OVER
FIVE YEARS THE TRUMP PLAN WOULD
PUT OIL DRILLING AND DEREK'S OF
RIGHT AT THE BOUNDARIES OF
SPECIAL AND PROTECTED FEDERAL
LANDS.
LIKE THE VENTANA WILDERNESS AREA
AND THE LOS PADRES NATIONAL
FOREST AND SEVERAL OTHERS THAT
BREAKING AIR POLLUTION RISKS OF
WATER CONTAMINATION INDUSTRIAL
OPERATIONS TRUCK TRAFFIC AND THE
DESTRUCTION AND DESTRUCTION.
OF HABITAT CONNECTIVITY FOR
WILDLIFE MOVING IN AND OUT OF
THESE PROTECTED AREAS.
WHILE THE STATE MAY HAVE LIMITED
AUTHORITY TO STOP THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION FROM LIQUIDATING
OUR PUBLIC LANDS. FOR OIL
INDUSTRY INTEREST THE STATE
SHOULD CERTAINLY NOT BE DOING
ANYTHING TO FACILITATE THE
EXPANSION FOR THESE REASONS WE
SUPPORT AB.
FOR THREE FORTY TWO ARE THERE
OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING JAMIE GO ON BEHALF
OF AUDUBON CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
CENTER FOR BIOLOGICAL DIVERSITY
ENVIRONMENT CALIFORNIA AS WELL
AS THE CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS AND SUPPORT.
BORN COMMISSAIRE CLUB CALIFORNIA
IN SUPPORT ALSO REGISTERING
SUPPORT FOR THREE FIFTY BAY AREA
ACTION FALSO FOR CALIFORNIA AND
THREE FIFTY SILICON VALLEY THANK
YOU [inaudible]
SIR OPPOSITION.
THERE ARE FILE.
YES WE DON'T HAVE AN APPROVED
PHYSICIAN ON THIS -- WOULD KNOW
THAT AT THIS TIME IT'S UNCLEAR
WHETHER THE STATE LANDS
COMMISSION A WILL INCUR
ADDITIONAL WORKLOAD TO EVALUATE
LEASE ISSUANCES.
A AN ADDITIONALLY ALTHOUGH IT IS
UNKNOWN -- THERE MAY BE
POTENTIAL LOSS OF FUTURE GENERAL
FUND REVENUE TO THE EXTENT THIS
BILL RESULT IN FEWER LEASES
BEING ENTERED INTO.
A THAN OTHERWISE WOULD HAVE
OCCURRED UNDER EXISTING LAW
[inaudible]
YOU MAY.
IF THIS BILL WERE DRAFTED RATHER
THAN PROHIBITING STATE AGENCIES
TO ENTER INTO NEW LEASES WHICH
IS I GUESS COULD PROMULGATE
REGULATIONS AND JUST HAD A
NEGATIVE.
APPROPRIATION YOU COULDN'T.
YOU COULDN'T YOU SPEND ANY FUNDS
WITH THAT.
LEVY AT A REQUIREMENT FOR
REGULATIONS HAVE JUST SAID WE
CAN'T PUT SPEND ANY STATE FUNDS
TO FURTHER THIS FEDERAL --
ACTIVITY UP I'D WANT TO GET TALK
TO OUR OF OUR DEPARTMENT AND GET
BACK TO YOU THIS IS JUST THE
APPROPRIATIONS IS A NEGATIVE
APPROPRIATIONS JUST OF SPENDING
MONEY VERSUS TELL US WHY WE
SHOULDN'T BE ENTERING LEASES.
SIR I CAN I CAN ADDRESS SAID --
SO THE THE THE ISSUE IS.
WHETHER OR NOT THE STATE
AGENCIES WOULD -- ISSUE LEASES
FOR PRIVATE COMPANIES TO BUILD
THE INFRASTRUCTURE ON STATE
LANDS IS SO BIG ISSUE AS IN AS
MUCH THE STATE FUNDS.
AS AS MUCH AS THE THE STATE
LEASES SO WE WE WANT.
TO JUST LIKE WE DID WITH THE
SENATE BILL EIGHT THIRTY FOUR
LAST YEAR WAS CENTER JACKSON'S
BILL. TO PROHIBIT -- PRIVATE
COMPANIES FROM -- FROM
DEVELOPING AND YOU KNOW
INSTALLING GOT PIPELINES AND
OTHER INFRASTRUCTURE NECESSARY
TO SUPPORT ANY NEW -- OIL
DRILLING -- ALL ON A GAS
DEVELOPMENT -- SERVICE SO AGAIN
THE THE THE FOCUS IS ON THE
PROHIBITION OF THE LEASES NOT
THE STATE FRANK AND AND THE
QUOTE THE QUESTION REASON I ASK
THE QUESTION IS THAT.
THAT WOULD BE FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS WHICH MAY BE WORTH IT
YOU KNOW THAT'S A GOOD THING
VERSUS IF IT JUST SAID DON'T
SPEND THE MONEY WILL BE ZERO IT
MAY NOT HAVE THE A FIFTY THE
PROTECTIVE EFFECT THAT.
HIS ACTION BUT JUST FOR THIS
FISCAL COMMITTEE I WAS JUST
LOOKING FOR THE DOLLARS
[inaudible]
OKAY THANKS [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
WE HAVE A MOTION ON THE BILL
WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE ALL
RIGHT WILL TAKE THE ROLE.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
SENATE FLOOR PORTANTINO PINE
PORTANTINO AYE BATES
[inaudible]
BRADFORD.
BRADFORD I DORADO.
DORADO AYE HILL HILL AYE JONES.
JONES NO WE CASKEY.
WITH KASKI I THE BILL IS OUT
BACK EVER MAKE YOU WE'RE GOING
TO LIFT THE CALLS STARTING WITH
AB TWO THREE NINE MISTER SALAS.
BECAUSE WE'VE TAKEN ALL THE DO
PASSES.
PLEASE LET THE CALL.
239- THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
THE SENATE FLOOR BRADFORD.
BRADFORD AYE.
THE BILL WAS OUT AB TWO FIVE TO
MISTER DALY.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
SENATE FLOOR BATES.
BATES AYE BRADFORD.
BRADFORD AYE HILL.
HILL I THE BILL WAS OUT. EIGHTY
SIX NINETY FIVE MEDINA.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
SENATE FLOOR BRADFORD.
BRADFORD AYE HILL [inaudible]
HILL I THAT BILLS OUT.
AB FIFTEEN OH FOUR MEDINA.
THE ROLE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
THE SENATE FLOOR BRADFORD.
BRADFORD AYE.
ED HILL HILL I THE BILL IS OUT.
GO TO AB -- EIGHTEEN THIRTY
LET'S CALL.
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE SENATE
FLOOR BRADFORD.
BRADFORD I THE BILL WAS OUT --
MOVING DOWN TO AB.
SEVEN SEVEN NINE PLEASE CALL.
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE SENATE
FLOOR BRADFORD.
BRADFORD I THE BILL IS OUT.
MOVING TO AB EIGHT OH SIX MR
BLOOM.
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE SENATE
FLOOR BRADFORD.
BRADFORD AYE.
THE BILL IS OUT MOVING AB.
TEN EIGHTY FOUR THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO THE SENATE FLOOR
BRADFORD.
BRADFORD AYE.
MOVING THE AB TWELVE THIRTEEN
HAVE TO CALL.
QUESTION IS DO PASSED THE SENATE
FLOOR BATES.
BATES AYE BRADFORD BRADFORD AYE.
HILL HILL AYE JONES [inaudible]
JONES I THE BILL WAS OUT.
AB.
TWELVE FIFTY TWO FIFTH CALL.
EMOTION IS TO PASS TO THE SENATE
FLOOR BRADFORD.
BRADFORD I THE MAN AB SEVENTEEN
FORTY FIVE PLEASE LIFT CALL.
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE SENATE
FLOOR BRADFORD.
BRADFORD AYE HILL HILL AYE JONES.
JONES I THE BILL IS OUT.
THAT IS EVERYTHING THERE'S
NOTHING LEFT ON CALL AND NO MORE
DO PASSES WE HAVE A FEW MORE.
SUSPENSE CANDIDATES [inaudible]
YES MA'AM. TWO FIFTY TWO TWO
FIFTY TWO DALY.
CAN YOU CHECK.
TO FIFTY TWO MAN THE SEVENTY
SEVEN ZERO OKAY I'M I JUST IN
HERE.
SO ALL RIGHT.
SO WE WILL GO BACK TO WE LEFT
OFF ON AB ELEVEN TWENTY SEVEN
RIGHT MS THREE OF US.
AND IS THERE ANYBODY HERE IN
FAVOR OF ELEVEN TWENTY SEVEN THE
WHOLE WITH THE CALIFORNIA STATE
PTA.
IN SUPPORT.
GREAT ANY OPPOSITION TO ELEVEN
TWENTY SEVEN ON IN OUR DISTRICT
ATTENDANCE [inaudible]
SIR FILE. TO THE EXTENT THIS
BILL INCREASES THE MOVEMENT OF
STUDENTS BETWEEN SCHOOL
DISTRICTS COSTS IN STATE FUNDING
OR SHIFTED FROM ONE DISTRICT TO
THE OTHER.
AND AT THE LOCAL LEVEL THIS BILL
COULD CREATE COST PRESSURES TO
THE EXTENT THAT SCHOOL DISTRICTS
OF OPPOSE ENROLLMENT.
MUST PROVIDE TRANSPORTATION TO A
NEWLY TRANSFER STUDENT AND
SCHOOL DISTRICTS THE PROPOSAL
ROLANDIS A IS A BASIC EIGHT
SCHOOL DISTRICT.
SEEING NO POOR ARE YOU UP FOR
THIS FROM NOW.
SEEING NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB ELEVEN TWENTY SEVEN
WILL GO TO SUSPENSE.
WE HAVE A BE FIFTH FOURTEEN
FIFTY TWO RESTAURANT DONNELL ON
STATE TEACHERS RETIREMENT IS
THERE SUPPORT.
WITH ONE MARTINEZ WAY WITH
CALIFORNIA STATE TEACHERS
RETIREMENT SYSTEM IN SUPPORT.
IS THERE OPPOSITION.
IS THERE A FILE.
THIS BILL WILL RESULT IN SOME
MEMBERS STARTING THEIR DEFINED
BENEFIT PROGRAM MEMBERSHIP A
MONTH EARLIER THAN UNDER CURRENT
LAW.
AND ACCORDING TO CAL STIRS THIS
CHANGE WILL BE APPLIED
PROSPECTIVELY TO AN ESTIMATED
TWENTY THREE MEMBERS A YEAR AND
WOOD MODESTLY INCREASE ANNUAL
GENERAL FUND CONTRIBUTIONS FROM
THE STATE TO CASTERS BY TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS.
SEEING NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION A. B. FOURTEEN FIFTY
TWO WITHOUT A SUSPENSE AB
SEVENTEEN THIRTY SEVEN BY MISTER
OBERNOLTE.
SIR ANYBODY IN SUPPORT.
SIR OPPOSITION SIR FILE.
THIS BILL COULD HAVE AN UNKNOWN
AND IMPACT ON FUTURE TRIAL COURT
EXPENDITURES AT A MINIMUM
LIFTING THE RESTRICTIONS ON THE
AMOUNT OF CARRY OVER FUNDING
FROM YEAR TO YEAR WILL LIKELY
RESULT IN A SHIFT OF
EXPENDITURES.
POTENTIAL IN THE MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS ANNUALLY TO FUTURE
FISCAL YEARS.
I WOULD ALSO NOTE THAT THIS BILL
IS INCONSISTENT WITH THE BUDGET
TRAILER BILL RECENTLY PASSED BY
THE LEGISLATURE.
WHICH INCREASES THE TRIAL COURT
RESERVE CAPS FROM 1% 23%.
SEEING THE QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB SEVENTEEN THIRTY
SEVEN WILL GO TO SUSPENSE.
I THINK THAT'S EVERYTHING THAT I
MISSION [inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
ORGAN [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
WE DID EVERYTHING THIS MEETING
IS ADJOURNED THANK YOU